serious the patriots were when it came
to spending in free agency we mentioned
that earlier one more clip from bill
belichick yesterday talking about that
process
of going all in like never before here's
the question he was asked and how he
went about answering it the way you
spent on offense
is that an indication that you feel like
what you surrounded cam with last year
wasn't enough to highlight what cam
brought to the table
well again the the process this off
season was to um
as it always is to try and improve the
team and and to try to do everything we
can to make
uh ourselves as competitive as we can
this year
which is what we try to do every year so
you know we had several years in free
agency where we were
you know one of the least cash spending
teams in the league and then this year
that changed and balanced it off and so
that's really what you have in the nfl
teams that
don't spend and spend teams that spend
and their years and they don't spend
so it averages that over a period of
time and that's
you know that's part part of the
averaging process came this year but
ultimately
we're trying to again do what we can to
improve the team like we always do every
year and
that's what we're going to continue to
do as we work through the draft process
and
other team building opportunities that
may or may not come along during the
season but they'll i'm sure there'll be
others
somewhere along the line and we'll
evaluate those when they present
themselves
peter he talks about the averaging
process what's the most intriguing about
this
they've never been part of the averaging
process on the spend side robert kraft
told you a few weeks
back those were the teams they made fun
of
in the past the teams that went out and
spent spent spent
knowing that they were overpaying for
guys who were not going to deliver that
championship that
teams delude themselves into thinking
they're going to buy in free agency but
this year they had to do it because the
cupboard was otherwise too bare
from a style a talent standpoint and
they had the cash
and the cap space because of what
happened with the pandemic
driving the salary cap down patriots
were in a spot where
need and opportunity came together
and we saw him do something we've never
seen them do
look the thing about the patriots that
is has
been unique over the years is that tom
brady has been able to be
a deodorant to hide a lot of
faults on this team and they don't have
that deodorant anymore they don't have
that guy who's going to be able to win
when your talent is down some so now
obviously after last year when they had
in my opinion
the worst collection of skilled players
of all 32 teams
in the nfl they woke up and they
basically
said okay let's go out and spend 96
million guaranteed or whatever the
guaranteed number is is incredible and
and let's go spend i think 175 million
on signing bonuses uh you know and all
that i
i just think mike that bill belichick
you know understands now that
you're not going to be able to win
unless you have some significant
weaponry on your offense you've got to
get
to the nfl in 2021 and
latin the last couple of years you saw
it starting with brady
late in the 19 season and in that
playoff loss to tennessee
they were awful at the skill positions
and and now what you're seeing
especially
you know exclamation point the retire of
julian edelman
retirement of julian edelman he can't
save them now
either so you know it's time to
get with the program and get with 2021
football
and get enough weapons to really help
your quarterback
now we're gonna see is cam newton any
good he wasn't last year
what was the reason weaponry covid we
don't know but he wasn't good last year
so now we're gonna get to see if cam
newton can be salvaged
with a bunch of good weapons around him
edelman one of the rare successes from
the standpoint of drafting and
developing and i think the developing
part of it
doesn't get mentioned enough peter
because it's not like
they are selecting players who are
otherwise not on anyone else's
board these guys that they're picking
would have been picked by someone else
at some point it's picking the guy maybe
at the wrong spot but then when he's in
the building it's
not developing him i'd love to know the
story behind that
does belichick get too impatient with
young guys they make too many mistakes
i'd rather just have the veteran here
we don't trust the young guy he never
has that breakthrough moment but they
just don't develop the young skill
position guys
either and that's one of the reasons
edelman stands out
so clearly because they developed the
hell out of julian edelman
a college quarterback who converted a
receiver and became a super bowl mvp
you know i'm going to write something in
my column monday about
you know sort of the you know the genius
of julian edelman
and and and how julian edelman happened
in the first place mike did you know
that uh when i was talking to him after
he won the mvp
uh a couple of years three years ago
whatever it was two years ago
after he won the mvp in the super bowl
he told me
that you know had had the the football
thing not worked out
i mean first of all his head coach at
kent state
wanted him to go to canada uh to play
football in canada and compete for a job
as a quarterback in canada and he
basically said
hey listen i want to be a pro football
player
but i want to play in the nfl i never
dreamed of playing in the cfl
not that there's anything wrong with the
cfl but i want to try to make the nfl
and of all the teams that worked him out
that year
it was really really interesting because
he was worked out
as a safety as a uh as a nickel
and also as a uh as a as a return man
uh you know as well as a as a receiver
and that year
that off season he worked with charlie
fry who was then a quarterback
on the cleveland browns he worked with
charlie frye learning the receiver
position
but you talk about you know how he was
helped on that team and here's what i'm
told
when he got there basically tom brady
when you get to the patriots you've been
drafted
by the patriots or you know you're
you're on the team
brady will basically start working with
you
until he senses that
you're not uh you're not working hard
and and and you're not going to be a guy
who
who i'm going to be able to rely on but
when that happened
with julian edelman that was the key to
him because tom brady
saw how hard this guy worked and he
would stay after and after and after
and you know and so those are the
reasons why guys succeed
in my opinion in new england you're
gonna get a chance
and as a receiver you're gonna get a
chance but
when the guy who basically is in charge
of determining
honestly whether you're gonna make it or
not if he sees
the desire the drive the work ethic he's
gonna beat you into the ground
to make it work with you same thing
happened when chris hogan went there
as a free agent so those are the kind of
things
that happened in new england now you
know we'll see what happens with the
tight ends this year
with cam newton and and how much
they're able to work together and a lot
of it too mike
is what are they going to be allowed to
do in this offseason
and i think that's going to be really
important in new england
those guys used to get together all the
time anyway
and now if they have organized workouts
or whatever it is
they're going to have to find a way to
get together this off season
we're going to be talking about that in
the next segment before we take our
break though you mentioned
julian edelman experimenting at the
nickel corner position
i still remember clearly him playing the
slot
against the ravens in a playoff game
once upon a time and
covering anquan bolden or more
accurately trying to
cover anquan bolton edelman picked the
right position ultimately to play other
than quarterback in the nfl because it
wasn't working
at defensive back even though he took 27
snaps out of 73 in that afc championship
game that the patriots ultimately won
over the ravens to cap the 2011 seas
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports